hello internet hello internet yeah
welcome to the field
we're gonna watch today from film three
i had a suspicion they'd be doing
something the secret villain of
loki is you
yep that's what it is let's watch it
we're the timekeepers
me i presume please if anyone is anyone
then i
am you i have an offer that's why i
found you let's hear it
i'm gonna overthrow the algorithm cards
on the table i could use a good
lieutenant yen
i don't know look just show yourself
this cold open ain't getting any colder
fine but be warned the truth isn't
always what you expect
yeah so that's the big twist huh
yep okay should we just hop into the
theory then oh
sorry sorry it was the slip of the
tongue
cool damn what good
what good effects hello internet
welcome to film theory where i encourage
you to hit that subscribe button and
ring the bell so we can magically appear
in your sacred timeline
of youtube videos speaking of blowing up
timelines holy cow does marvel studios
know how to use their chaos magic to
turn
wednesdays on social media into one big
nexus event the first episode of the new
disney plus series loki set
record numbers and considering the
reveals that happened last night the
social posts aren't slowing down anytime
soon
i feel like every time there's a new
marvel show they set
new record most watch it and i can
believe it but it gets to a point where
i'm like
is this just the thing they keep saying
now we're only on the third marvel show
on
disney plus so i mean it's not a very
crazy bar to have to
keep here today are they getting a
little overzealous being like only
wednesdays now
i mean just as it looked like episode 2
was settling into a comfy episodic
groove kablooey another huge bombshell
as it's revealed that the variant loki
r loki is chasing on behalf of the tva
is a woman
[Music]
female loki oh and she also set off a
bomb that maybe blew up reality as we
know it and may have just recreated the
multiverse and here you thought the
gender reveals that started forest fires
were bad anyway we've still got four
episodes left to go in this thing
who or what else could we be seeing next
kid loki
lucky charms loki colonel sanders loki
i hope so but admit it you wouldn't be
surprised i see you colonel sanders
i see you white clad finger looking good
loki's aside this is a show where
literally
anything is possible i mean the central
conceit is all about time travel
alternate timelines weapons that rewind
and fast forward individual people
grenades that can blow up entire
realities monsters that can cast
illusions
duplicate themselves and use mind
control even a cosmic bureaucracy
seemingly so powerful that they can
vaporize demigods and use infinity
stones as paperweights we actually get a
lot of those
i mean not only is everything on the
table but like
everything is on the table that's why
it's good i'm not here today to try and
predict what's going to happen in the
show
instead i'm here to predict what the
show is about yeah
those are two very separate very
distinct things though admittedly i
might also throw in some what's going to
happen stuff in here too
no what i'm interested in today is the
meta text
the stuff that's happening around the
margins of this story because two
episodes end i'm getting a strong sense
of where this is
all headed and what the goal of this
show really is i mean with all that you
just said that
that is what's going to happen
yeah mainly what you have described is
what's going to happen
they're intertwined what's it about is
different but
sounds like you're mainly talking about
what's going to happen
and then a little bit of what's it about
based on that and if i'm right well then
i think i know who the real bad guy of
loki is
it's you so let's unpack this behold
my stuff what we're doing today is a
type of literary criticism called new
historicism
literary criticism is basically a fancy
word for interpreting a work of art and
supporting your analysis with evidence
basically a slightly more sophisticated
version of writing a five paragraph
essay for your english class and there
are
lots of different ways to do it you can
look at the historical context around a
work you can look at the author and
their beliefs you can ask whether the
author is a socialist or a feminist or
has an unconscious oral fixation that's
coming out through their work or you can
just ignore
all of that stuff and just read the darn
book or watch the darn movie and analyze
that don't worry we're not going
anywhere
near that deep new historicism criticism
looks at the work in its historical
context under the belief that hey
this book or movie isn't just a product
of an author but the product of a moment
in history
if you really want to understand what
it's interesting you have to also
understand the historical context into
which it was published
right right right is what we're about to
do with loki to understand why beneath
everything else this is a show about
us and our relationship with the current
state of marvel
so let's start with the very top
interesting shall we start with what we
experienced
we see take place on screen loki the
series follows
shock of all shocks loki not the same
one that we know from the first 14 years
of mcu movies he's still dead
most likely instead this loki is the one
from end game who grabbed the tesseract
and escaped into a portal when the
avengers kind of bungled their time
heists
like the first seven years except what
no one expected was that the new
timelines don't get to split off for
very long
apparently there's a way overpowered
cosmic police agency called the time
variance authority that monitor things
like when a stray loki goes rogue and
immediately swoop in to collect them
drag them off to tva
hq for processing and set off suspicious
looking grenades that appeared to delete
incorrect timelines from existing right
right yup if you'd been waiting however
long for one of these things to answer
whether or not a marvel cinematic
multiverse exists loki has your answer
no the tva makes sure that
but that was a bad thing because all the
different realities kept fighting with
each other
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war
which you know is going to be the
premise of a movie one day
you know
i mean like i and everyone else watching
this scene on premiere night
immediately demanded it from our
mouse-eared overlords
anyway moving on supposedly the
multiverse problem was solved by a trio
of omnipotent cosmic beings called the
time keepers blasting the whole shebang
into a single reality called the sacred
timeline a single beginning to end
straight line telling one true version
of the story and the tva's role is to
make sure that the past
present and future all still happen the
way they're supposed to by preventing
variants like the escaped loki from
creating nexus events
which spin off into alternate timelines
now why does that word sound so familiar
nexus because the world doesn't revolve
around you
just him recapping what we learned
i'm just like day of this show is so
cool
i know it's so cool all the sci-fi you
want
and i gotta say too in terms of the
editing on this video so far again as
always film theory
the graphics and editing top-notch stuff
and also you know with the fact that
matpat was just talking about how
this show will possibly be dealing with
like a meta commentary on our
relationship with marvel
itself i am hoping because you know like
the second we put up our video yesterday
so many of the comments were about
multiverse multiverse multiverse and
madness and stuff like that
which i totally understand and respect
why people are so hyped about it my hope
is that what we mainly keep talking
about is the context of what's going on
within the plot and the characters of
the show loki itself and not so much
about
multiverse of madness yeah even though
i'm very chat for that
too because especially after the events
of the last episode i'm like yeah i'm
right there with you guys but i want
that to be the main talk
take it one piece of the story at a time
and this piece is loki yeah cause this
piece is phenomenal but instead of
erasing our variant loki from existence
entirely
tva agent mobius wants to put him to
work catching a rogue
loki that's causing all sorts of
problems so that's what's happening on
the surface but now let's go one layer
deeper into the themes of the show
based on this initial premise are pretty
darn clear identity
freedom versus determinism and the
possibility of redemption
i mean the whole plot is loki literally
on a quest
to find loki he doesn't get any more
explicit than that
and not only is he tasked with finding
himself but he also has to learn who he
himself is in a sea of
himself and in a world where his
decisions are predetermined as the first
episode
says you ridiculous bureaucrats will not
dictate how my story ends
it's not your story mr laughs and it
never was
and again with lady loki this isn't
about you
and that my friends is our big question
in a world where everything is
predetermined by a sacred timeline what
does it mean be free
go figure the guy the matrix is on the
side of upsetting the apple cart and not
being told what to do whereas the tva
believes that the sacred timeline has to
be upheld no matter what which leads to
probably the easiest prediction theory
that i've ever had to make on the
channel
the time variance authority are not the
good guys in the story
what no that is shocking go figure the
regime of time
space middle managers are bad despite
them saying that they're good who would
have thunk it
it's not like there were any signs along
the way like say their minutemen field
agents dressed like heavily armored riot
cops their processing centers
deliberately evoking the beige
fluorescent lit dehumanizing mazes of a
dmv or a small claims court and their
entire overall aesthetic evoking a mix
of mid-century american meets early
soviet bureaucracy
not too hard to read this writing on the
wall but what's even more concerning is
their philosophy
especially in the mcu where
individuality free will
and the idea that we are not bound to
our fate are like the core moral
components to almost every major hero
nebula bucky barnes heck even the
original loki changed his ways to fight
against hela and thanos that's
not how the tva sees it instead mobius
informs loki that his evil nature was
always the plan in the sacred timeline
right up until it wasn't that his only
real purpose was to be a bad guy for the
good guys to become
good guys by defeating him you weren't
born to be king loki you were born to
cause
pain and suffering and death that's how
it is
that's how it was that's how it will be
all so that others
can achieve their best versions of
themselves
but here's the kicker they don't really
have an explanation for why
things have to be how they are you see
this is a big
part of why i've been loving a lot of
the subtext and storytelling of
loki in particular from the first
episode we had our suspicions like the
cva really
good by the second episode a lot of us
leaned a lot more towards
i don't know this tv it definitely seems
like they're bad it's a common opinion
that a lot of us have like he said
a very predictable theory that we can
have about the show
they're not like hamming up or making it
abundantly obvious
that the tva is bad there's still a part
of us that's
sort of holding back on fully declaring
it we had a big discussion about it i
think it was in the new rockstars vid
that we covered yesterday depending on
the perspective of the situation
you're likely to lean towards that the
tva is bad but why we don't lean there
immediately is because the character
they capture in the
beginning of this series is a bad
version of loki loki who just
tried taking over the world just went
toe-to-toe with the avengers this was a
bad
loki so in that perspective you're like
okay now that makes sense he's a bad guy
he escaped yeah tva must be doing the
right thing
yeah then as we're going through it
you're like i know there's a bit of a
prison vibe to what they're doing you
know
yeah and i mean that suits very well the
sort of like taking a look at the
current time and place the show is set
in because there are a lot of you know
agencies that are sort of portrayed this
way but also that we as
you know just collective populations
have a lot of suspicion around
what he was talking about with identity
one of the first questions we asked to
the writer michael waldron
was will this be the definitive version
of loki he came back with an answer of
does this guy become the definitive
version
can there be a definitive version of
loki maybe
that's the question we're told the
multiverse was bad to begin with but
well we
we don't actually know if that's true
we're supposed to take them at their
word even though the time keepers stay
out of sight and apparently only
directly communicate with judges
the timeline is sacred because the time
keepers
say it is period just take it on faith
the whole thing
sounds an awful lot like a religion with
objects
like beings communicating their will
through a chosen few that you just gotta
believe
heck in episode two when loki finally
asks what the end of the whole big story
is mobia says that
they don't know they're waiting for the
timekeepers to untangle it and fill them
in
how does it all end that's a work in
progress
oh there's lazy timekeepers what are
they waiting for
contraire no because while we protect
what came before
they are toiling away in their chamber
untangling
the epilogue from its infinite branches
i see
so when they're finished what happens
then so are we
in other words the tva doesn't even know
what they're fighting
dying and running cosmic
[Music]
that sentence is loki her name is ravono
renslayer
in the comics this name belongs to a
princess consort and on-again-off-again
romantic
interest to kang one of the most feared
and powerful
marvel villains ever and wouldn't you
know it he just so happens to be a
villain from the future
obsessed with reordering the timeline to
ensure his victories using time travel
reality hopping and illusions to get
exactly what he wants
sounds an awful lot like the time keeper
is supervising the tva doesn't it and i
learned from my mistakes watching wanda
vision if it looks like
a darkness and wears a brooch like an
agatha harkness then chances are it's an
agony that's an argument
with a close no it's a festival in every
episode lingering on that final face in
the center of the courtroom
just saying there's a chance that all
these stories are connected
it also helps that actor jonathan majors
is believed to be playing kang the
conqueror in the upcoming ant-man and
the wasp movie
so we know that there's a high
likelihood that this guy's gonna show up
in the relatively near future but now
it's time to get into i mean that's
confirmed
of this whole thing the meta narrative
think about what role the time keepers
play
in the metanarrative of loki's story so
far omnipotent beings who are aware of
everything that's ever happened or will
ever happen
and who have the ability to send ultra
powerful agents to any place in the
universe at any point in time
but instead of rescuing people from
danger or stopping disasters or even
trying to make anything better they're
exclusively concerned with making sure
that the events on a timeline that they
decided was the right version
the sacred version no less continues to
happen in the way that they already know
them to have happened despite all their
titles these guys aren't keeping time
they're keeping
continuity those stunning jack-booted
thugs with batons going around
literally beating up variants and
blowing up mistakes that's meant to be
us
that marvel meta narrative is pointing
back at fans who might be getting ready
to ruin everyone's fun because the
timeline isn't perfect the dark hold
from agents of shield doesn't look
exactly like the darkhold from wanda
vision
and in case you think that seems to be a
little on the nose for the moral of the
series remember captain marvel ended
with
every guy who complained about the
concept of carol danvers being
overpowered gets ragdolled across the
desert
prove to me you can beat me
meanwhile it's pretty clear based on how
the series is turning out in the
upcoming slate of films that loki is
either going to end with fracturing the
sacred timeline or is setting the table
for that to happen
early on in doctor strange multiverse of
madness
the worst kept secret in hollywood is
that marvel's next big trick is
probably that a cinematic universe is
about to become a cinematic multiverse
the sony marvel partnership is doing
another animated spider-verse movie
pretty much everyone already knows that
spider-man no way home is
some kind of multiverse movie as well
there's references to both the mcu
and the sam raimi spider-man movies in
the trailer already confirmed
morbius and they're about to launch an
animated anthology series entirely about
alternate realities whatever they
ultimately decide a multiverse
means in this context the marvel
multiverse is coming
probably pretty soon it's a good way to
manage the expanding roster of
properties it lets you revisit
characters you've otherwise retired you
can try out ideas that might not be
ready for the mainstream
as well as keep characters who might not
play well with everyone else like
deadpool blade and punisher safely in
their own spaces you could use it as a
hand wave to pull in established
characters you've acquired from
elsewhere but keep them in their more
famous forms all while
fixing inconsistencies scratch
everything i said earlier let's only
talk about the multiverse match
all the possibilities every characters
like the ladies describe it like that
that's why we're excited for the
multiverse
absolutely because the possibilities are
endless but what he's talking about with
this setup with the multiverse of how
this is sort of like a meta commentary
towards us our expectations our
emotional response to
like you know like i was using the
darkhold as an example and then how this
multiverse can also help put some things
at ease appease us in some way i
appreciate
that approach to where he's going with
that what i think what marvel's doing
they're doing a good job with provoking
their audience i think
sometimes it doesn't go over so well
like a ralph boner
for example but then what they're doing
here could possibly help
smooth the situation like that if it is
heading this direction where like the
x-men from fox universe can exist
along like the marvel multiverse
universe then
cool then we still have uh evan peters
quicksilver right from the first episode
alone like what happened with the
infinity stones that raised so many
questions calling them paper weights
a lot of people were kind of confused on
you know what does that really mean does
it
undercut it and i like the provocative
nature of what this show is doing so far
and also
how it's coming up with these like
philosophical theoretical questions
that are getting us all pondering beyond
multiverse and that's why i'm saying
like
i'm loving that what they're doing with
multiverse is doing more than just
opening up the door for that
it's also creating a lot of fascinating
questions about our experience with
marvel before the mcu as well it's it's
a really
really cool stuff they're doing doing
this audience tug and pull with our
emotions
from working within the multiverse
context i think is fun
a lot of people hate that [ __ ] i i kind
of loved it
a lot they're directly engaging with the
audience through the material
yeah i love how they'll challenge but
the thing about a multiverse is
just like miss minutes says in episode 1
they're messy they're chaotic
things get jumbled up so do you kowtow
to the time keepers and limit yourself
to a strict deterministic series of
events like the tva
blindly following a path towards some
unknown ends or
decide with loki and loosen up a bit and
allow for a little bit of chaos cause
guess what
chaos can be kind of fun well if i'm
right about this and i'm feeling good
about it so far
then the loki series is marvel telling
us their decision
a little bit of mess is worth it in the
long run because it lets them do more
fun stuff when it comes down to a choice
between avoiding a continuity error or
doing something awesome
they are going to try to do something
awesome does time travel mean that
suddenly steve rogers stayed oddly
silent throughout national tragedies
like the vietnam war
how did dr strange get everyone
organized for the big final portal
charge shouldn't he have intervened at
some point throughout the entirety of
wandavision mistakes like that are gonna
happen but isn't it worth it just to
hear falcon's voice over cap's earpiece
on your
past or in left of the mcu the real
statement lady loki was making when she
bombed the sacred timeline was all about
the series's meta-narrative
not just putting the timekeepers on
notice for whatever their canonical
agenda is but telling
us to brace ourselves for the messy the
chaotic but the much more
interesting and narratively fulfilling
multiverse to come
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cut dan that was a good video
the concern that comes to
mind though is like yes do you get to
have more experimental crazy wacky [ __ ]
you can do
yeah and that's what i'm looking forward
to the same time you know sometimes the
concern that pops into my mind which i
don't really have like a big worry that
marvel will like fail at this i'm
pretty confident they'll succeed in
order to make it all work
to create a more a fluid narrative to
all this
don't get to mumbo jumbo just like
that's one of the concerns of spider-man
no way home but everything
that we're hearing is like that still
has to be a good solo movie
you know like with a show it's different
you got a lot you got like six
to seven hours to explore all this so
you don't
have to like jam it imagine trying to
jam all loki this into one movie no
it wouldn't work spider-man no way home
like using that as like part of their
final image
my concern comes in is as they're doing
all this multiverse stuff making this
new
sort of narrative with it that their
standalone movies still have to
really work on their own and stuff to be
good films even while adding to the
world building that you're doing with
the multiverse that's just the little
thing that i'm a oh it could have big
consequences with bad movies
but but it is a conservative yeah with
the show not really with a movie
yeah well that's the big thing that
makes me curious now is how the movies
are going to react to the shows because
right now the most recent things we've
had have all been shows
yeah you know so we have this next slate
of movies coming up what will those look
like how will they differ structurally
how will they
acknowledge the events of the shows and
stuff like that it's fascinating to
think about and i certainly hope that
there is at least
some visible change in them we'll see
how it goes guys
i guess we are the secret villains of
loki we demanded our multiverse
so that's why we're the building and i
know we got it yeah
and hope we're happy all right guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that like button hit that
notification bell subscribe to filter if
you haven't done so already this is
wonderfully put together
love their videos see you guys